all right here now with reaction we have
house oversight committee chairman James
comr along with the chairman of the ever
so important house Ways and Means
Committee Jason Smith uh chairman comr
let me start with you let me get your
general reaction to all of
this yeah well I mean I'm not surprised
uh look this is one of many crimes that
Hunter Biden has committed we believe
that if you're going the tax evasion
route not only did he evade taxes on the
obvious income that that why charged him
with but also the loans and that's
something that Jason Smith and the Ways
and Means Committee are looking into as
well uh we believe that if you look at
the loans that that uh J Jim Biden and
Hunter Biden had there's over $13
million in loans a and no trace of
principal payments much less interest
payments so at what point does a loan
become income we believe there's
significantly more tax liability than
what he has we also know that there's
moneya laundering uh we get that from
all the suspicious activity Reports most
of the 170 suspicious activity reports
at treasury implied that the bidens were
money laundering and from what we can
look at with their uh bank statements
now and and the research we've done I
can confirm uh it sure looks like Loney
laundering to me you also have the
obvious violation of the foreign agents
registration act and who was he lobbying
for he was lobbying for China Russia and
some of the worst countries on the world
but also he was lobbying his father so
that makes Joe Biden liable in foreign
agent uh registration act liability so
we've got a lot of concerns here this is
the tip of the iceberg I'm not surprised
it happened before this week uh but this
case is far from being over how much
money are we talking about
Congressman well we know they've gotten
over 24 million uh from our enemies
around the world now we're finding all
these loans uh Jason Smith just released
the the parts of the transcript uh from
the whistleblowers you've heard John
Solomon break the story that there's
another uh an additional $3 million that
he may owe Kevin Morris what are the
terms of that is he ever going to pay it
back if you have a loan for years and
years and years and you don't ever pay
any payments on it or have any intention
of paying it back then that's income uh
if you take $13 million in loans that
we've identified with the president's
family that's another $4 million in
federal income taxes that they would owe
in addition to evading taxes I mean
there are many many problems here but at
the at the heart of this is Joe Biden
all of this Revenue came because of Joe
Biden Joe Biden knew what his son was
doing he knew what his brother was doing
he met with all the people even though
he said he never met with them he
continues to lie about it he did it this
week this is a concern We Fear this
President is compromised we know he's
been dishonest with the American people
and that's why we're pressing forward
with the impeachment inquiry next week
let me ask you Congressman uh Smith uh
we learned a lot more this week in your
committee where Gary shapley and Joe
Zigler uh testified before your
committee what did you learn this week
that we didn't know
before first off Sean we would not be
where we are today if it was not for
those two Brave whistleblowers that came
before the Ways and Means Committee back
in May that led to all of the items that
have been pointed out in fact they
highlighted all of the tax crimes that
were charged yesterday that they should
have been charged years ago they've also
highlighted how the justice department
obstructed their investigation in ways
that they have never seen before and and
they highlighted in fact where numerous
leads led to President Joe Biden but
they were halted stopped in their tracks
search warrants with public figure one
being President Biden were removed there
was numerous numerous examples that led
to President Biden for example Kevin
Morris that was mentioned by Mr comr the
gentleman who who originally paid off $2
million of of Hunter Biden's loans they
testified this week that it's it's in
fact 4.9 million of loans and payments
that Kevin Morris has delivered to
Hunter Biden and what's really important
they also delivered an email that Kevin
Moore sent the tax preparer for Hunter
Biden saying we have to pay these tax
returns or it will be personally and
politically liable that was three weeks
before super Tuesday which ultimately
decided Joe Biden is the nominee the
Democrat nominee for president well let
me ask you this too all right we have
all of the lies told I'll ask both of
you the same question we have the
suspicious uh activity reports we have
all all these shell companies that
you've identified the sheer amount of
money tens of millions of dollars uh no
services that we can identified rendered
we we have what 10 family members that
have gotten paid including uh grandkids
uh can you explain to me how much money
we're talking about and how
sophisticated this was James
comr yeah I mean it's over $30 million
now and uh we have no idea what they did
to receive the money were they lobbying
those countries if so that's simple
that's a foreign agents registration act
violation that's a penalty of up to 5
years imprisonment and $250,000 fund so
we've got a lot of questions for Hunter
Biden about specific transactions this
may a $100,000 wire here a $5 million
wire there he told One Bank examiner it
appears that that $5 million wire from
China was a loan it look it appears he
told another bank examiner that it was a
fee for lobbying either way he's in
trouble because either way he wasn't
telling the truth from what uh we
believe the the real answers are so
that's why we're bringing him in for a
deposition we have hundreds of specific
questions that we
have it's also about Joe Biden isn't
it it's more it's about this is an
investigation of Joe Biden Joe Biden
knew about this and if he been honest
with the American people from day one he
he may have gotten away with this but
the fact that he said he never met with
any of these people he never talked to
any of these people that that Hunter
Biden uh had a wall between his personal
life and the government all of this to
is proven to be false and now the fact
that we found these panm emails tens of
thousands 82,000 PM emails that Joe
Biden used many of them were sent to
people he swore he never even talked to
so and and the fact that they're
covering this up Sean it's not only the
crimes the bid have committed it's the
cover up the government should be held
accountable every single person who was
involved in this cover up and that's the
goal of what Jason Smith and I are
trying to do along with Jim Jordan all
right we'll give you the last word Jason
Smith uh where do you see this going in
terms of Joe
Biden well this this entire
investigation is about Joe Biden I agree
with what chairman comr just said we are
looking at from the Ways and Means
Committee I want to see the tax returns
the tax returns that President Biden has
publicly released there's no indication
that he ever received any interest
income however we know that he's
received more than
$240,000 worth of loan repayments from
his brother those loan repayments should
have interest income and if the
president wasn't reporting interest
income that's a crime his son just got
charged with nine tax crimes yesterday
apparently it might run in the family
and by the way you would have to pay
interest right for it to be a real
loan absolutely in order for it to be a
real loan you would have to pay interest
if you did not it would have to be
recognizing your taxes as a gift which
you would also have to pay taxes on all
right chairman comr chairman Smith thank
you both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to Subs subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else